ان امريكا والسعوديه مستعدتان لاستئناف
المباحثات السودانيه بمجرد ان تبدي
الاطراف الجديه
الرئيس الامريكيه يقول انه سيوقع على
مشروع قانون سقف الدين السبت
288 قتيلا ومئات الجرحى في حادث تصادم بين
ثلاثه قطارات شرقي الهند
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
هذه النشره الاخباريه ندد مجلس الامن
الدولي بعمليات النهابه التي تعرضت لها
المساعدات الانسانيه والهجمات التي
استهدفت المدنيين في السودان وداع مجلس
الامن لوقف الاعمال العدائيه والاتفاق على
وقف دائم لاطلاق النار بهدف بدء عمليه
سياسيه تفضي الى الديمقراطيه واكد الدول
الاعضاء في المجلس دعمها للبعثه الامميه
في السودان معبره في الوقت ذاته عن قلقها
من تاثير الصراع في السودان على دول
الجوار كما دعا مجلس الامن المنظمات
الدوليه واعضاء الامم المتحده للاستجابه
بسرعه للاحتياجات الانسانيه في السودان من
جهه اخرى رحب اعضاء مجلس الامن بتوقيع
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع في الحادي عشر من مايو في جده
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه على اعلان
الالتزام بحمايه مدنيين في السودان هذا
واكد اعضاء مجلس الامن اهميه قيام
المواقعين على اعلان جده بتنفيذ هذه الال
بالكامل
في السياق مدد مجلس الامن الدولي عمل
البعثه السياسيه للامم المتحده في السودان
سته اشهر وجاء التمديد رغم اتهام قائد
الجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان لرئيس
البعثه بالاسهام في تاجيج النزاع يذكر بان
بعثه الامم المتحده انشات في يونيو عام
2020 لدعم العمليات الديمقراطيه
الانتقاليه بعد نحو عام على الاطاحه بنظام
عمر البشير
استمرت الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع وسط مدينه الخرطوم
وغربها حيث تصاعدت اعمده الدخان من
المنطقه الصناعيه للمدينه من جهه ثانيه
هدات حده القصف المدفعي الذي شهدته مدينه
ام درمان في الساعات الماضيه والذي تسبب
في تضرر بعض المنازل وبعيدا عن ام درمان
رفع الجيش السوداني من وتيره القصف
المدفعي خلال الايام الماضيه اثناء
استهدافه لمواقع تتمركز فيها قوه الدعم
السريع
هذا وعبر مواطن سودانيون عن احباطهم بعد
اقرار تعليق المفاوضات السودانيه فيما
استذكر البعض ميزات الهدنه الماضيه التي
عاشها السودانيون
الهدنه احنا كنا بنتحرك لكن الساعه بعد
وقف المفاوضات دي يعني بقينا ما بنقدر
نتحرك نمشي للسوق ما قاعد نمشي للاسواك
واقفين نهائي المفاوضات يعني كان في امل
انه الحياه ممكن تمشي لقدام شويه اقلها
المساعدات كان بتصل
اسئله
يعني الناس داخلها ام درمان هنا تقضي
اغراضه يعني وتجيب استسلاماتها من الاسواق
وبعد
الهدنه انتهت فبقت صعبه يعني
العديد من وكالات الاغاثه العامله في
السودان بالصعوبات التي تواجهها من اجل
ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه للمدنيه واشتكت
منظمه اطباء بلا حدود تعرض المستودعات
تابعه لها للنهب فضلا عن الاستيلاء على
الكثير من الشاحنات التي تنقل المساعدات
وكشف مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه بان 162 شاحنه على الاقل تابعه
لمنظمات الاغاثه تعرضت للسرقه كما صرح بان
نحو 120 مكتبا ومستودعا تابعا ايضا
لمنظمات اغاثيه تعرضوا لعمليات نهب من
جهاته كشف برنامج الاغذيه العالميه تابعه
للامم المتحده بانه فقد امدادات في
السودان بقيمه 60 مليون دولار خلال الصراع
هذا وقال مسؤول بالسياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه بان الولايات المتحده والسعوديه
على استعداد للاستئناف واستئناف المباحثات
السودانيه المعلقه بمجرد ان توضح الاطراف
الجلديه في الامتثال لوقف اطلاق النار من
جهته ارشاد المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي جون كيربي بالجهود التي
تبذلها السعوديه لحل ازمتي السودان واليمن
ونوى كيربي بالمساعي المتواصله للرياض الى
جانب واشنطن من اجل اعاده طرفي الصراع في
السودان الى طاوله التفاوض
[موسيقى]
الى الولايات المتحده حيث قال الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن بانه سيوقع اليوم السبت
على مشروع القانون الذي اقره الكونغرس هذا
الاسبوع لرفع سقف الدين الامريكي ليصير
قانونا واعلن بايضا بانه ما من شيء سيكون
اكثر انعداما للمسؤوليه واكثر كارثيه من
تخلف الولايات المتحده عن سداد ديونها
اود ان اثني على رئيس مجلس النواب مكرفي
كما تعلمون هو وانا نحن وفرقنا تمكنا من
التوافق وانجاز الامور كنا صريحين مع
بعضنا البعض صادقين تماما ومحترمين مع
بعضنا البعض كلا الجانبين عمل بحسن النيه
والجانبان حقق وعدهما اود ان اشكر اعضاء
الكونجرس الذين صوته لتمرير هذه الاتفاقيه
التي ساوقعها السبت لتصبح قانونا
نجاح الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ورئيسي
مجلس النوابه كيفن مكرفي بالتوصل الى
اتفاق حول سقف الدين وتمريره في مجلس
النواب ومجلس الشيوخ بتصويت من الحزبين
يشير الى فشل اقصى اليسار واقصى اليمين
بعرقله توافقات الزعامات الكبيره في
واشنطن فرغم المعارضه القويه لهذين
التيارين في الحسبين والتي وصلت الى تهديد
تجمع الحريه الجمهوري في مجلس النواب ببدء
اجراء عزل مكارتي من منصبه اذا مرر مشروع
القانون باغلبيه ديمقراطيه لم يابها الرجل
للغايه بشان الامر ولا يبدو ان ذلك اثر
كثيرا على موقفه التفاوضي اعتقد الكثير
انه وضع في الزاويه لكونه مدينا لهذه
المجموعه لكن كما ترون من الاحتجاج الساخب
بسبب عدم اعجابهم بهذه الصفقه انه لم يكن
لديهم ضغط عليه كان قادرا على العمل مع
الديمقراطيين لانجاز ذلك تمرير المشروع في
الكونجرس عكس توافق نادرا لم منذ سنوات
بين القيادات المعتدله من الحزبين
الجمهوري والديمقراطي حسب عدد من
المتابعين وهو ما فسره البعض بان القضيه
متعلقه بمساله بصريه
هذه الصفقه ستستمر لعامين اي بعد
الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه لقد ارادوا
اخراج هذا من الطريق ليترشحوا لاعاده
الانتخاب جميع النواب وثلث اعضاء مجلس
الشيوخ وبالطبع الرئيس السؤال هو هل
سيتمكنون من تكرار ذلك لكن كان لافتا خلال
نقاشات مجلسي النواب والشيوخ انتقاد اعضاء
كل حزب للحزب الاخر واتهامه بالتسبب
بالازمه حتى المؤيدين للصفقه رغم الاتفاق
عليها بل ان بعضهم عاد وصوت ضدها
لمقاطعتهم وولاياتهم كان هناك اشخاص خاصه
للغايه للصفقه لكن بعدما علمت انها ستمرر
صوتت وتحدثت ضدها لان الامر متعلق بقدره
النواب على العوده الى ناخبيهم والقول
انهم صوتوا ضد المشروع بغض النظر عن كل ما
حدث يرى الكثيرون ان تمرير المشروع انتصار
سياسي وتشريعي لكل من بايدن
حسين الطاود العربيه واشنطن
[موسيقى]
اعلنا وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن
بان الحوار بين الولايات المتحده والصين
ضروريه وبانه سيتيح تجنب الحسابات الخاطئه
التي قد تؤدي الى نزاع تصريحات استون جاءت
بعدما رفضت بكينه دعوه الى عقد اجتماع
الرسمي بينه وبين نظيره الصيني اقل في
حوار شانجريلا في سنغافوره بان الولايات
المتحده تعتقد ان خطوط الاتصال المفتوحه
مع الصين امر ضروري ولا سلم بين مسؤولي
الجيش في البلدين
هذا وزاره مدير وكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه ويليام في مايو الماضي
حيث التقى نظرائه في اول زياره لمسؤول
امريكي بهذا المستوى الى الصين منذ اسقطت
واشنطن فبراير من طادا صينيا حيث شدد برنس
خلال زياره على اهميه ابقاء قنوات التواصل
المفتوحه على صعيد الاستخبارات
قال مستشار الامن القومي بالبيت الابيض
جيكسوليفان بان الولايات المتحده ستلتزم
بحدود الاسلحه النوويه المنصوصه عليها في
معاهده نيو ستارت حتى انتهاء سيران هذه
المعاهده في عام
2026 اذا فعلت روسيا الشيء نفسه
ليس من مصلحه بلدينا الشروع في منافسه
مفتوحه في القوه النوويه الاستراتيجيه
ونحن على استعداد للالتزام بالحدود
المركزيه طالما فعلت روسيا ذلك وبدلا من
انتظار حل جميع خلافاتنا فان الولايات
المتحده مستعده لاشراك روسيا الان في
اداره المخاطر النوويه وتطوير اطار عمل
للحد من التسلح لما بعد عام 2026
نحن على استعداد للبدء بهذه المناقشات
اشار مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيك
سوليفان الى ان الصين اختارت عدم الجلوس
الى طاوله الحوار بخصوص الترسانه النوويه
التي قد تصل الى 1500 راس نووي حربي بحلول
عام
بحلول عام 2035 ستكون جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه في طريقها لامتلاك ما يصل الى
1500 راس حربي نووي وهي واحده من اكبر
التعزيزات النوويه في وقت السلم في
التاريخ ولكن على عكس روسيا التي تهدد
بالابتعاد عن طاوله المفاوضات وعن
اتفاقيات الحد من الاسلحه التي تحالفت
عليها بلداننا لسنوات فقد اختارت جمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه عدم الجلوس الى الطاوله
لاجراء حوار موضوعي بشان الحد من التسلح
هذا واكد نائب الامين العام لحلف الناتو
خلال مؤتمر صحفي للامن الاقليمي في
سنغافوره بانه يجب على الصين ان تكون اكثر
شفافيه بشان حجم الترسانه النوويه لافتا
الى ان سرعه عمل بكين محطه اهتمام حلف
الناتو لافتا الى ان الناتو منفتح على
الحوار لكنه لا يمكن ان يكون ذلك مكان
الحوار بين الولايات المتحده والصين
اهلا بكم من جديد ارتفعت اخر حصيله لحادث
تصادم ثلاثه قطارات شرقيه الهند الى 288
[موسيقى]
افادت وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه بوصول ثلاثه
اوروبيين الى بروكسال بعد اخراج ايران
عنهم وقبل ذلك قال متحدث باسم الحكومه
البلجيكيه بانه تم تبادل الاوروبيين
الثلاثه مقابل الدبلوماسيه الايرانيه اسد
الله اسد ضمن صفقه تبادل سجناء بين ايران
وبلجيكا واوضح المتحدث باسم الحكومه
البلجيكيه بان الامر يتعلق بنمساويين
اثنين ودنماركي وشهدت الصفقه اطلاق سراح
ايران لعامل الاغاثه
البلجيكيل الاسبوع الماضي واذن اسدي في
بلجيكا عام 2021 بمحاوله تفجير قنبله في
فرنسا وحكم عليه بالسجن عشرين عاما
[موسيقى]
افادت مصادر في كوسوفو باستمرار
الاعتصامات لليوم الثامن على توالي امام
بلديه
في شماليه الاقليم فيما انطلقت دعوات
لاعاده الانتخابات كمدخل للحوار ورفض
المحتجون وهم من الاقليه الصربيه في اقليم
كوسوفو مغادره مكان الاعتصام الا بعد
الغاء قرارات تعيين رؤساء بلديات من
الالبان وقال المعتصمون انهم لا يرفضون
الحوار مع الحكومه ولكن الحوار مشروط
باعاده الانتخابات البلديه هذا ويتواصل
وجود الحشود الامنيه في محيط البلديات حتى
الساعه وخاصه في سبيتشان منعا لوصول
المحتاجين الى داخل المباني ياتي هذا على
خلفيه رفض سكان البلديات في شمال الاقليم
ذات الاغلبيه الصربيه نتائج الانتخابات
التي اجرتها سلطات كوسوفو
العواصم الغربيه تسابق الزمن لنزع شوكه
الاضطرابات المستمره في كوسوفو واشنطن
باريس برلين وغيرها دخلت على الخط داعيه
اطرف النزاع لايجاد حل للازمه ووضع حد
لنزيف العنف الذي هز شماليه
[موسيقى]
الحل المقترح للازمه اجراء انتخابات جديده
بمشاركه صربيه واسعه مقترح يطمح الى اطفاء
نار غضب المحتجين الصرب الرافدين للانتخاب
مرشحين البان لرئاسه اربع بلديات شماليه
كوسوفو
بريشتينو مع مقترح اعاده الانتخابات لكن
تحت شروط كوسوفو بوسعها اجراء انتخابات
جديده في الشمال بمشاركه الصرب ان جرت
بشكل قانوني
انتخابات لاعاده بشكل قانوني اذا بينما
موقف صربيا ليس واضحا بخصوص هذا المقترح
في هذا الخضام لم تاتي بعد الجهود الحثثه
المبذوله لاحتواء الاوضاع ثمارها فالتوتر
لا يزال سيد الموقف توتر دفع قوه حفر
السلام التي يقودها حلف الناتو الى
استقدام تعزيزات عسكريه من بولندا لسيطره
على الاوضاع وكان شبح توتر قد اطل من جديد
في الثالث والعشرين من شهر ابريل الماضي
حين اجريت انتخابات محليه في اربع بلديات
شماليه كوسوفو ذاتي اغلبيه صربيه انتخابات
قاطعها الصرب لتشهد مشاركه 1500 ناخب فقط
من اصل 45 الفا مسجلين بنسبه مشاركه لم
تتجاوز 4% فتيل المواجهات اندلع بشكل فعلي
في الخامس والعشرين من شهر مايو خلال
تسليم الرؤساء الالبان مناصبهم وهو ما
استفز الاقليه الصربيه
المتمركزه في هذه المنطقه هي اذا قنبله
موقوته تعلم اوروبا جيدا ان انفجارها في
الوقت الراهن قد يجر عليها ويلات صراع
جديد هي في غنى عنه وسام الذهبي العربيه
هذا واوضحت بيانات وزاره الصحه اليابانيه
بان معدل المواليد في البلاد انخفض للعام
السابع على توالي في عام 2022 الى مستوى
قياسي منخفض الامر الذي يلقي الضوء على
ازمه ديموغرافيه مع تقلص عدد السكان
وارتفاع سريع في نسبه المسنين
[موسيقى]
الصرخه حلما يراود اليابانيين اصوات تنخفض
تدريجيا في الدوله الحاديه عشره من حيث
عدد السكان بحسب احصاءات وورد ميترز
يتكاثر الوجود البشري بهم وبزديادهم اما
يصبحون عبئا او يدا تشد على زمام العجله
الاقتصاديه وفعلا هذا ما يؤرق اليابان ذلك
البلد الذي يقدر عدد سكانه باكثر من 126
مليون نسمه ويمثل واحدا فاصله 62% من
اجماليه عدد سكان العالم يشكو قله في عدد
المواليد
تداعيات كورونا ونقصان الزيجات سببان
اساسيان لانخفاض عدد المواليد بنسبه خمسه
في المئه اي الى نحو 770 الفا في العام
الماضي وذلك مع تسجيلها اكثر من سبعه
واربعين الف حاله وفاه اثرى الجائحه
منذ بدايه العقد الاول من القرن الحادي
والعشرين اذا استمرنا في هذا الاتجاه
فسينخفض عدد الشباب بسرعه في العقد الثالث
من هذا القرن بضعف المعدل الحالي
راجع منذ 17 عاما هو سابع انخفاض على
التوالي يشيء بازمه ديموغرافيه تقترب مع
توتر الاوضاع ومن المتوقع ان ينخفض من نحو
126 مليون الى 87 مليون نسمه بحلول عام
2070 اذا لم تتخذ الحكومه ما يكفي من
تدابير جذريه لمعالجه الانكماش السريع
والشيخوخه السكانيه اسراء الصغير العربيه
قال باحثون بريطانيون بان فحص الدم لاكثر
من 50 نوعا من السرطان اظهر نتائج واعده
في تجربه كبرى لهيئه الخدمات الصحيه
الوطنيه البريطانيه
بريطانيا تقلب الموازين التقليديه وتدخل
اوسع ابواب الطب
باختبار دم ثوري يكشف اكثر من 50 سرطان
كشف تحليل الدم الذي سمي جاليري نتيجه
فوريه دقيقه وصحيحه بواقع ثلاثه وتسعين
بالمئه نوعين من كل ثلاثه انواع من
السرطان لدى خمسه الاف شخص في خمسه
وثمانين بالمئه من تلك الحالات الايجابيه
تم تحديد الموقع الاصلي للسرطان عن طريق
فحص عينه الدم فقط بينما تم اثبات اصابه
قرابه 75% من المرضى بالسرطان باختبار
الدم ليس ذلك فحسب بل وصحح نتائج ظهرت قبل
التحليل السلبيه بواقع 2.5
تحليل جاليري بانه مغير لقواعد اللعبه
فوفقا للباحثين من جامعه اوكسفورد يستطيع
هذا التحليل التعرف على انواع السرطانيه
صعبه وتشخيص في المراحل المبكره مثل
سرطانات الراس والعن المبيض والبنكرياس
والمريء تعتمد اليه عمل الاختبار على بحث
التغييرات مميزه في اجزاء من الشفره
الوراثيه التي تتسرب من انواع السرطان
المختلفه والخفيه تستخدم هيئه الخدمات
الصحيه الوطنيه البريطانيه اختبارك جاليري
على الاف الاشخاص حول البلاد لمساعده
الاطباء على اكتشاف حاله السرطان بصوره
مبكره ثم تدخل السريعا لانقاذ حياه المريض
وفي حال اثبتت نتائج العام الحالي
الاوليه نجاحها تخطط وهيئه الصحه
ببريطانيا توسيع النطاق ليشمل مليون شخص
اضافي خلال العامين القادمين
[موسيقى]
بان لبنان احتل المركز الاول عالميا في
الانفاق على السيجار هذا الاحصاء اعتبرهم
كثيرون صادما خصوصا وان لبنان يعاني من
ازمات اقتصاديه غير منتهيه وفقر يخيم على
معظم مواطني هو بلد تناقضات كما سماها
البعض في حين شكك المعنيون باستيراد
السيجار في لبنان في دقه هذا التقرير لعده
اسباب فلنتابع التفاصيل
في بلد يعاني من اسوا ازمه اقتصاديه جاء
الاول عالميا في الانفاق الفردي للسيجار
تقرير صادم اعتبره البعض محاكاه لتخدر
الشعب وتاقلمه مع الازمات لذا قررنا
الدخول الى محل احد مستوردي السيجار
للوقوف على حقيقه ما جاء في هذا التقرير
مختلف الاصناف معروضه وكانها تتباهى
بكماليتها تعرف انها مهما صعب امتلاكها
لاسعارها المرتفعه الا انها في لبنان
دائما تجد عشاق لها
هوايه هو شغف وهو كمان
صار يعتبر مثل الاستثمار يعني واحد يعمل
في مثل الساعات مثل الذهب او اي شيء ثاني
كل واحد على حسب
حسب البادجيت تبعه كل واحد حسب عيشته حسب
طريقه عيشته انا السيجاره عندي يعني انا
دخن سيجار يومي كل يوم احصاء نشره موقع
ستاتي افاد بان اللبنانيين يتفوقون على
الامريكيين البالغين من حيث الانفاق على
السيجار حيث جاء لبنان في المركز الاول
تليه امريكا ثم قطر نحن بلبنان كنا شهدنا
فتره من ال 21 22
بدنا نسميها هجمه بدنا نسميها سياحه
سيجاريه
كانت للتسوق السيجار كانوا يجوا من كل دول
العالم يشتروا من عنا سيجار وياخذوه لبرا
كان يجي ينباع بلبنان ويطلع لبرا اعاده
تصدير اعاده تصدير بس مش رسمه الرجي بيعه
بعشره مليون و700 الف دولار بالسنه بدنا
ناخذ هذا الرقم بيطلع عنا رقم كبير بينما
نحن اذا بنجي بندرس انه نحن بالتوانتي تو
كان الجمرك كان الجمرك على 1005 رغم هذا
التوضيح الا ان التقرير تحول الى ماده
السخريه بين اللبنانيين لبناني
بالميه ثلاثه بالمئه اربعه اللي بشرب
سيجار الاغنياء وبيت بابا بابا ما في حدا
لبنان مدمر نهائيا الاكيد ان لبناني يعيش
انهيارا غير مسبوق لكن مواطنيه يحاولون
بقدر استطاعتهم الحفاظ على نمط العيش
ولو مع بعض المساومات نهد يوسف العربيه
بيروت
ارسلت كندا
للجيش للمساعده باخماد الحرائق في شرقي
البلاد هذا وتشهد كندا موجه حرق قياسيه
ساهمت بتاجيش حرائق غير مسبوقه اجتاحت
الساحل المطل على المحيط الاطلسي واجزاء
اخرى من البلاد وكان اكثر من 200 حريقا
استعر في جميع انحاء البلاد بما فيها اكثر
من 80 حريقا خارج السيطره
في الختام تذكير بابرز العناوين
تقول بان الولايات المتحده والسعوديه
مستعده لاستئناف المباحثات السودانيه
بمجرد ان تبدي الاطراف الجديه
الرئيس الامريكيه يقول بانه سيوقع على
مشروع قانون سقف الدين اليوم
288 قتيلا ومئات الجرحى في حادث تصادم بين
ثلاثه قطارات شرقي الهند
في الختام شكرا للمتابعه والقاكم بعد قليل
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات